foreign
over the last decade marketing campaigns
have gone through an exciting
transformation thanks to technological
advancements and changing consumer
behaviors traditional marketing methods
such as TV commercials and print ads
have been joined by digital marketing
techniques like social media and
influencer marketing
this rise of personalization has been a
game changer in marketing allowing
Brands to create targeted and individual
methods that resonates with the audience
additionally there has been a shift
towards creating authentic and
meaningful connections with consumers
with storytelling and emotional
connections becoming a crucial for
Success another exciting trend has been
emphasizing social responsibility and
sustainability in marketing campaigns
with companies showcasing their
commitment to Social and environmental
causes to attract consumers who share
those values overall marketing campaigns
over the last decades have became more
diverse personalized and socially
conscious opening up to new and exciting
opportunities for Brands to connect with
their audience meaningfully but before
we begin let me take you through simply
learns professional certificate program
in digital marketing or better known as
a postgraduate program in digital
marketing it is the postgraduate program
course by simply learn in collaboration
with Purdue University at meta blueprint
in digital marketing this comprehensive
program is designed to equip you with
skills you need to excel in the
fast-paced world of digital marketing
with this program you will learn
everything from fundamentals of digital
marketing to the latest trends and
techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore topics such
as SEO sem content marketing social
media marketing email marketing and much
more the program is led by industry
experts who bring their real world
experience to the classroom giving you
an Insider perspective on what it takes
to succeed in the digital marketing
world
and with Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out and the
competitive field now if you are looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing or postgraduate
program in digital marketing is the
perfect place to start with to learn
more about this course you can click on
the link in the description box below so
with this hey everyone I am vaibo
khandival and I welcome you all to
Simply learns YouTube channel today we
will review some of the best marketing
campaigns over the last decade but
before we get into these memorable
marketing campaigns let me ask you a
question
which of the following marketing
campaigns goal focuses on increasing
brand awareness
first we have a lead generation B
customer retention C sales promotion and
D branding now stay tuned until the end
of this video to find the answer
meanwhile you can drop your answers in
the comment section below let's start a
journey
let's go down the memory lane and start
with 2013.
our first campaign is Oreo's daily twist
campaign
the Oreos daily twist campaign in 2013
was a marketing success story to
celebrate its 100th anniversary
Oreo released a new image of cookie
every day for 100 days each featuring a
different pop culture reference or event
happening that day the photos were
shared on social media platforms
creating a bus and increasing Oreo
social media following by hundred and
ten percent the campaign success was
attributed to its timely and relevant
content and Innovative use of social
media to engage consumers the daily
twist campaign has become a case study
in successful social media marketing
proving the power of tapping into
current events and Trends to create
engaging and shareable content during
that same year Google also launched its
Google project rebrief trajectory brief
was a Google advertising campaign
launched in 2013 aimed at updating
iconic ad campaigns from 1960 using
Google's technology the campaign focused
on four classic ads and generated 5.3
million views on YouTube increasing
Brands awareness and engagement for all
companies involved it was several
advertising Awards including a dense
lion and a Webby award demonstrating the
power of combining modern technology
with classic advertising campaigns the
project showed that digital marketing
can refresh iconic ad campaigns while
staying true to the original Creative
Vision
in 2014 we embarked on a new era of
social media challenges
with alss Association ice bucket
challenge the ice bucket challenge was a
viral social media campaign in 2014 that
raised over 220 million dollars
worldwide amiotrophic lateral sclerosis
ALS over 17 million people participated
including celebrities and politicians
and the campaign had a massive impact on
social media with over 2.4 million
Facebook videos and 1.2 million tweets
using the hashtag
ice bucket challenge the funds raised
helped accelerate ALS research resulting
in the discovery of new ALS genes and
new drug therapies Guinness World
Records recognized the ice bucket
challenge as the largest ever social
media campaign for a course the campaign
was a remarkable example of how social
media can be used for a good course
highlighting the individual's power to
make a difference during all this time
when fast food giant McDonald's also
launched its McDonald's our food your
questions campaign in 2014 McDonald's
Canada launched the r food your question
campaign to address concerns about the
quality of its food the campaign invited
customers to ask any question they had
about the food and McDonald's promised
to answer them honestly since then
campaign has responded to over 42 000
question and has been so successful that
it has been rolled out in other
countries McDonald's created a website
and a social media channel dedicated to
the campaign receiving millions of
visits and engagement the campaigns
success has been evident in surveys with
96 percent of the Canadians finding it
helpful and 88 saying it improved their
perception of the brand the campaign has
grown several Awards in including a
golden lion against Lion International
Festival of creativity
our food your question is a successful
example of how transparency and open
communication can help build customer
Trust
in the Epic age of 2015 we got a little
adventurous with Volvos the Epic split
campaign
in 2015 Volvo launched its the Epic
split campaign featuring actor
Jean-Claude Van Damme performing a split
between the two moving Volvo trucks the
campaign aimed to showcase the stability
and precision of Volvo trucks the video
went viral receiving over 100 million
views on YouTube in just over two months
and over 10 million shares on social
media
according to the study by Google and
ipsos the campaign led to 31 increase in
Volvo truck orders in the first quarter
of 2014. it won several Awards including
a Grand Prix against Lion International
Festival of creativity the campaign
success was evident in its sequel the
Epic split 2 which featured a similar
stunt but this time between two
reversing trucks the Epic split is an
excellent example of how a creative
marketing campaign can capture the
Public's attention and drive sales
meanwhile Apple came up with the Apple's
shot on iPhone 6 campaign
apples shot on iPhone 6 campaign in 2015
invited iPhone 6 users to submit their
best photos taken with their phone which
were then featured in the ads worldwide
the campaign was huge success with over
10 000 photos being submitted from users
in 140 countries the ads featuring these
photos were displayed on Billboard print
ads and social media platforms worldwide
the campaign resulted in a 13 increase
in iPhone sales during the quarter it
rained which led to its continuation on
for future iPhone models shot on iPhone
6 won several Awards including a Grand
Prix against Lion International Festival
of creativity this campaign demonstrates
the power of user generated content in
marketing campaigns showcasing the
products capability Through The Eyes of
its users the campaign success is a
testament to Apple's commitment to
Excellence in its products and marketing
efforts
in 2016 we went a little political with
heikens World apart campaign
highkins World apart campaign
aimed to address political polarization
by bringing together people with
opposing views the campaigns video ad
featured pairs of strangers with
opposing political views working
together to build a bar discovering
their differences during the build they
were then given a choice to stay and
have a beer or leave without drinking
this ad became the most watched ad on
YouTube in UK in 2017 generating over
3.5 billion media Impressions worldwide
the campaign resulted in a 7.1 percent
increase in sales volume proving the
campaign's effectiveness in engaging the
public and generating interest in the
brand the world support campaign won
several Awards including a Grand Prix
against Lions International Festival of
creativity its success LED high-end cans
to continue to open your poll campaign
in future ads the campaigns in in fact
demonstrates the power of marketing to
address social issues and engage in
meaningful conversations with consumers
now during all this most of the Young
Generation embarked on their Pokemon
Journey with Pokemon scores launch
campaign the launch campaign for Pokemon
go in 2016 was a cultural phenomenon
that took the World by strong
the augmented reality game allowed users
to catch Pokemon in the real world
generating over 500 million downloads
within two months of its release the
campaign was a massive Revenue generator
earning over 14 million in its first
week and was highly talked about social
media generating over 2.5 million tweets
the game was recognized for its success
receiving the best mobile game award at
the game awards 2016. the launch of
Pokemon go also had
significant impact on the gaming
Industries as the game's popularity
paved the way for the development of
augmented reality Games The Campaign
success is a testament to the power of
innovative and engaging marketing after
an augmented reality failed 2016 we
enter virtual reality in 2017 with
Samsung's ostrich campaign
the Samsung's ostrich campaign in 2017
aimed to promote the gear VR headset by
showcasing the possibilities of virtual
reality the campaign's video ad featured
an ostrich that learns to fly in the
virtual world set to the iconic music of
Elton John's Rocket Man the ad became
the most shared of 2017 and generated
over 4.3 billion views worldwide as a
result of the campaign Samsung imported
a 70 increase in Gear vr's headset sales
proving the effectiveness of this
program it won several Awards including
a Grand Prix at the cans Lion
International Festival of creativity the
campaign success led to the creation of
a sequel Turtle which continued the
theme of animal experiencing virtual
reality the ostrich campaign is an
excellent example of how Innovative and
Creative Marketing can generate interest
and excitement and boost cells during
2017 we also got inspired by Adidas
impossible is nothing campaign this
campaign was a powerful campaign that
aimed to inspire individuals to overcome
obstacles and Achieve greatness
featuring notable figures such as
Muhammad Ali David Beckham and Lionel
Messi The Campaign generated over 1.5
million views on YouTube within 24 hours
of its release the campaign also
significantly impacted edista's stock
price which rose by 1.8 percent
following its release social media was
also buzzed with the campaign generating
4.3 billion Impressions and 50 000
mentions within the first two months of
the campaign the website received over 2
million visits the impossible nothing
campaign was recognized for its success
receiving a cancer line Grand Prix award
among others overall the campaign's
message of preservatives and achievement
struck a code of with many inspiring
them to overcome their obstacles
we kick-started a 2018 listening with
music with spotify's 2018 gold campaign
this campaign used user data to create
numerous ads centered around New Year's
resolution the campaign versus
resounding success with over 1.6 billion
Impressions and 13 million clicks they
add relatable and personalized nature
led to is 24 percent increase in app
install which in turn led to 40 percent
increase in monthly active user the
campaign also received positive feedback
on social media with user uploading the
personalized and numerous approach the
ad had a click-through rate of over 28
percent higher than spotify's average
for previous campaigns demonstrating the
importance of relevance and engagement
in advertising campaign success was
recognized with the Keynes lion Grand
Prix award cementing spotify's position
as a leader in debt driven advertising
in 2018 a brave brand came in support of
social justice schools with Nike's
believe in something campaign
Nike's believe in something campaign in
2018 featured Colin kaspernick a former
NFL quarterback and aimed to support
social justice causes
the campaign generated over 5.82 billion
media Impressions an increase Nike's
online sales by 31 percent equivalent to
an estimated of 163 million in free
advertising however the campaign was
also contribution with hashtag Church
Burnet trending on Twitter and initially
caused Nike's stock price to fall
despite the backlash the campaign won
several Awards including the a
prestigious Kansas golden Grand Prix
award recognizing its impact and success
Nike's bold approach demonstrated the
power of advertising to make a statement
and drive change while showcasing the
company's willingness to take a stand on
important social issues in 2019
was ear of some healthy competition
between burger joints when Burger King
launched its Burger King Whopper details
campaign in 2019 Burger King launched a
woper detour Campaign which offered
customers a one set bopper if they use
Burger King app within 600 feet of the
McDonald's location this creative and
humorous promotion generated over 1.5
billion earned media Impressions and led
to 37 increase in Burger King app
campaign success was driven by 300
increase in Mobile orders and the Burger
King app rose up to top of both Apple's
App Store and Google Play Store charts
social media users praised the
campaign's humor and cleverness leading
to the positive feedback and numerous
Awards including against lion Grand Prix
award overall Burger King's woper detour
campaign demonstrated the value of
originality and engagement in marketing
campaigns mean while Amazon decided to
connect with its customers heart with
Amazon's delivering smile campaign the
delivering smile campaign in 2008-19
aimed to showcase the company's
commitment to customer satisfaction by
creating an emotional connection with
the customer the campaign featured a
heartwarming video of a delivery driver
delivering a package to a delighted dog
which generated over 25 million views
and was shared widely on social media
the campaign helped to improve Amazon's
brand image with customers praising the
company's delivery service and its
dedication to delivering happiness to
its customers by highlighting the
importance of creating emotional
connections with customers Amazon was
able to stand out in the crowded market
and build stronger relationship with its
customers in the week of covid-19 in
2020 proved to wake courageous year
for the healthcare workers so to
celebrate their courage to help others
Dove came up with its courage is
beautiful campaign it was a tribute to
the courageous healthcare workers who
put their lives on the line to save
others during the covid-19 pandemic the
campaigns was focused on Marx left by
PPE on healthcare workers faces conveyed
the sacrifices made by those in the
healthcare Industries to care for the
sick durf's campaign generated an
impressive 2.2 billion Impressions on
social media as people across the world
praise the brand for highlighting The
Bravery of Frontline workers the
campaign also helped to enhance Dove's
image as a company that cares about
important social issues
this inspiring campaign demonstrated how
a brand could leverage its platform to
drive positive societal changes by
recognizing and supporting those who
came a difference in the world while
Microsoft helped young girls to make
their space in a male dominated industry
with Microsoft changed the game campaign
this campaign was designed to encourage
girls to pursue careers in the gaming
Industries the campaign highlighted
stories of four young female Gamers and
their achievements in the gaming World
Microsoft's effort to promote diversity
and inclusivity in the gaming industry
was well received with campaign
generating 230 million impressions on
social media platform the campaign also
resulted in a 76 increase in online
searches for women in gaming and a 54
increase in search for female Gamers
this positive response to the campaign
demonstrated the importance of
representation and its impact on
inspiring the next generation of women
in gaming
Microsoft's change the game campaign is
a powerful example of how Brands can use
their platform to create positive change
and promote inclusivity in traditionally
male dominated Industries in 2011 many
companies played a big role in spreading
positivity in the hard times that came
with covet 19. Coca-Cola's open to
better campaign aimed to promote
positivity in the optimism in the wake
of the covid-19 pandemic the campaign
encouraged people to embrace the change
and be open to new experiences and
opportunities Coca-Cola launched a
series of ad that showcased stories of
people who found unexpected
opportunities and positivity during the
pandemic the campaign generated over 1.3
billion Impressions on social media and
was widely praised for its uplifting
message additionally
launched a global sustainability
initiative as a part of the campaign
pledging to use 50 percent recycled
materials in its packaging by 2030. the
initiative also included a commitment to
carbon neutrality by 2040 by promoting
positivity and sustainability
Coca-Cola demonstrated its commitment to
making a positive impact on the world
during this stay-at-home season Spotify
came up with it only you campaign this
campaign aimed to personalize the music
streaming experience for its users the
campaign was centered around a feature
that generated unique playlist based on
the users listening history and
preferences the feature also included
series of data driven insights such as
the genres and the artists a user
listens to the most
the campaign generated over 4.4 billion
streams of custom playlist and was
widely praised for its innovative
approach to personalization in addition
the campaign included a series of
billboards and social media ads
featuring quirky and relatable insights
into users listening habits the campaign
showcased spotify's commitment to
leveraging data to create personalized
and engaging user experience
in 2012 after such hard three years
digital marketing also made its special
place and became a big part of
Industries in 2022 HubSpot came up with
a full swing with and introduced
thousand Integrations HubSpot a inbound
marketing Sales and Service platform has
recently hit a major Milestone by adding
our thousand apps to its Marketplace to
celebrate this achievement the company
launched a multi-channel campaign that
showcased its own facility and
highlighted the contributions of its
integrated Partners this move not only
served to inform existing and potential
customers about the wide range of
capabilities available but it also
really the partners Network to share in
the success and take pride in their
involvement the Milestone event
underscores the importance of a strong
and motivated Network working together
to create powerful solution that can
drive business growth and success
meanwhile credit showcased its
creativity with reddit's brand awareness
Super Bowl advert Super Bowl ads are the
Holy Grail of advertising offering
Brands a coveted spot in front of their
target audience and or one in two NFL
fan discovering new products through TV
ads and 41 percent of the Americans
watching or following the NFL
it's no surprise that ad slots are
selling at a premium in 2022 a 30-second
ad slot during the Super Bowl cost
around 6.5 million dollars
the most expensive in NFL history while
some brand opt to extend their ad slots
rated took a different approach with a 5
Second ad that left viewers confused and
curious starting as a generic card promo
it suddenly cut to a glitch like screen
text and horses galloping through the
field the ad was so cryptic that many
viewers thought it was an accident but
it got people talking reddit's tweet
about the ad dragged up for 64
000 views on social media making it one
of the most talked about and memorable
ads of the day proving that a small ad
can add spot can make a big impact so
these were some of the best most
memorable marketing campaigns of the
last decade now let's go back to the
question we've asked at the start of
this video so the current answer is
option D branding
so branding campaign aims to increase
brand recognition recall and awareness
among the target audience such campaigns
aim not to generate leads or promote
sales but to establish the Brand's
identity and reputation to the market
branding campaigns often use social
media advertising influencer marketing
and content marketing to engage with the
audience and build up a strong brand
image and with this we have come to an
end of this exciting video
I hope you guys found it informative and
helpful if you like this video then
upward this video and hit that subscribe
button which campaign inspired you the
most you can let us know in the comment
section below we will be back with more
exciting and interesting videos until
then stay safe and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you